Take education today,
I used to go to high schools,
give speeches.
All the times politicians do.
I'd look out over that high school group
and we'd had an interaction.
My fractions may not be right here,
but 50 percent of those kids I don't
need to worry about.
Uh,
they come from good homes.
They go to their churches,
they have good healthcare.
They're involved in their community.
They may not all be a students,
but they're doing well.
Many of them are a students and we're
not gonna.
Screw those kids up.
They're going to make it and they're
going to do well in life.
What bothers me is that other half
now,
there was a time when we were so good
and so strong and so powerful as a
country,
but we didn't really need to worry too
much about that other half.
But that's changing now and we've got to
begin to bring them up.
And that means the educational system
has to be sharply improved.
So I worry about these things and many,
many others.